Just about anything can be changed with texture mapping. Beyond color and
alpha, here's an example of changing the shininess for different locations on
the body. The face is fairly shiny. The back of the head and shoulders less so.
Here are the color and specular textures for the face. In 3.js, the specular
map uses the red channel of the texture as the strength of the specular
contribution. A level of 255 means the specular component is scaled to one. In
other words, full strength dropping off as this value falls. Your task is to
apply a texture as a specular map. See the exercises code for the path to the
texture. Look at the online documentation for how to set the specular map for
mesh fong material. On the left is the teapot without the specular map. Once
you're done, you'll see a teapot like the one on the right. As you change the
view, you'll see that just the specular highlights are textured.